ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen in
Deutschland muss mehr gebaut werden und
zwar so dass alle sich das leisten
können was Sie gerade brauchen egal ob
sie mieten oder kaufen und egal ob sie
wenig Geld haben oder viel darüber waren
sich heute alle einig beim Krisengipfel
mit der Baubranche im Kanzleramt aber
die Bundesregierung müssen noch viel
mehr tun und vor allem muss alles viel
schneller gehen fördert die Branche
Kanzler Scholz und bauministerin gaivitz
haben heute 14 Punkte vorgestellt damit
mehr gebaut wird mehr Hilfe für
Familieneigentum z.B und weniger
energieauflagen für Neubauten was
Umweltverbände dann auch gleich
kritisiert haben
reicht das war das ein guter Gipfel oder
werden die Mieter im Stich gelassen
darüber möchte ich gerne mit euch und
Ihnen diskutieren eure und ihre
Meinungen einholen und die spreche mit
einem Vertreter aus der
wohnungsbaubranche dem Präsidenten des
Mieterbundes und einem Experten für
Immobilienwirtschaft und damit wir alle
über das gleiche sprechen fast
Christiansen die Lage zusammen und der
greift genau das auf was eine Userin
schon im Chat geschrieben hat da habe
ich nämlich eben schon mal reingeguckt
und sehr auf Youtube schreibt Vesna
Marit ich erinnere mich dass unser
Kanzler Scholz gesagt hat er werde
Wohnungen bauen und dann kommen sehr
viele nachdenkliches Smileys und genau
damit fängt das Stück auch an
wenn ich sage was wir hinkriegen wollen
ist jedes Jahr 400.000 Wohnungen zu
bauen und damit nicht aufzuhören dann
ist das nicht unlösbar sondern etwas was
man anpacken muss liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde ein Wahlkampf Versprechen von
Olaf Scholz 2021 zwei Jahre später ist
klar es bleibt bei einem Versprechen das
Ziel wird verfehlt im letzten Jahr gab
es nur rund 295
000 neue Wohnungen 2023 dürften das noch
einmal deutlich weniger werden und
perspektivisch sieht es in den nächsten
Jahren sogar noch schlechter aus
die Rahmenbedingungen für den
Wohnungsbau in Deutschland sind nicht
einfacher geworden das hat was zu tun
mit dem russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine der dazu beigetragen hat dass
viele Preise gestiegen sind für
Materialien die auf dem Bau gebraucht
werden auch für Energie und Baukosten
und natürlich haben wir alle
gespürt dass die Inflation auch sich
niedergeschlagen hat Familien Rentner
Studenten alle mit dem gleichen Problem
und den gleichen Fragen finde ich eine
Wohnung die bezahlbar ist und bleibt
tja und dazu begrüße ich jetzt hier im
Stream meine beiden Gesprächspartner und
das sind wie schon angesprochen Lukas
siebenkotten er ist Präsident des
Deutschen Mieterbundes schön dass Sie
dabei sind und Axel gidaschko erst
Präsident des GdW des Bundesverbandes
der deutschen wohnungs- und
Immobilienunternehmen schön dass sie
beide heute Abend hier mit im Stream
dabei sind in diesem Format sind wir ja
immer eine große Community die ihre
Fragen sammelt und dann auch an sie
stellt und weiterreicht und wenn ich
hier rein gucke dann sehe ich das ein
Thema ganz viele Userinnen und User
beschäftigt nämlich das Thema
Zuwanderung deshalb würde ich das gerne
direkt am Anfang mit Ihnen besprechen
denn wir haben es gerade gesehen
Studenten Rentner Familien alle suchen
Wohnungen und was die Userinnen und User
hier sehr umtreibt ist die Frage ob es
da einen Zusammenhang gibt hier schreibt
zum Beispiel ein User es braucht eine
wirksame Begrenzung der Zuwanderung um
die Wohnungsnot zu lindern
einschließlich fester Grenzkontrollen
ich fange mal bei ihnen anhängerkotten
ähm ist das eine
berechtigte Sorge womit kann man wie
kann man damit konstruktiv umgehen dass
Menschen
Ängste haben dass der Wohnraum zu knapp
wird für alle
also inzwischen das muss man sicherlich
sagen ist der Wohnraum bereits für viele
zu knapp das liegt nicht in erster Linie
an der Zuwanderung bzw auch nicht in
erster Linie an geflüchteten sondern das
liegt auch an einer Binnenwanderung also
innerhalb Europas und der EU alle
Prognosen von vor 10-15 Jahren dass die
Bevölkerung zurückgehen würde haben sich
ja als falsch herausgestellt wir werden
immer mehr aber man muss das von zwei
Seiten betrachten die andere Seite ist
nämlich die dass es Fachkräfte gibt die
wir unbedingt nach Deutschland locken
wollen die wir unbedingt gebrauchen hier
und wenn wir denen erzählen du kannst
jetzt zwar arbeiten kriegst auch Geld
dafür aber eine Wohnung haben wir leider
nicht dann ist das sicherlich nicht die
richtige Lösung also es ist sehr
differenziert ja die Tatsache dass viele
Menschen in unser Land kommen führt auch
dazu dass wir noch mehr Wohnraum
benötigen aber bevor das richtig losging
hatten wir schon viel zu wenig Wohnraum
ist ihr Blick auf diese Dinge ähm wie
kann man damit umgehen und welche Rolle
spielt das
also der Lukas 7 konnten hat absolut
Recht der Blick ist genau der richtige
und das Fehlen von Wohnraum haben sowohl
der Deutsche Mieterbund als der GdW
gemeinsam seit Jahren egal welche
Regierung der herrscht hat schon
angemahnt wir haben auch insbesondere
gemeinsam angemahnt verschärft dagegen
zu steuern indem gerade in dem Bereich
der wichtig ist nämlich den bezahlbaren
Wohnraum mehr passiert und insbesondere
in den bezahlbaren Mietwohnungsbau und
da haben wir eigentlich das wahre
Dilemma weil unsere Unternehmen nicht
mehr in der Lage sind dieses bezahlbare
wohnen herzustellen wenn wir heute bauen
dann bauen wir für 18 bis 20 €. das
heißt wir können den Preis nicht liefern
wir können die Masse nicht liefern und
am Ende des Tages ist es fast keine
Frage mehr wer eigentlich zu uns kommt
weil
verstörender Weise werden wir überhaupt
nicht irgendwie irgendjemanden noch
künftig befriedigen können wenn es darum
geht dass er eine Familie gründen will
dass er umziehen muss weil er einen
neuen Job hat also wir sind in einer
dramatischen Situation weil wir
Fachkräfte brauchen die all diese
Wohnungen auch bauen jetzt vertreten sie
ja beide eigentlich zwei sehr
unterschiedliche Branchen einmal die
Mieter und Mieterinnen und einmal die
der
immobilienbauunternehmer lassen Sie uns
mit den Mieterinnen und Mietern mal
anfangen wie ist ihr Blick auf die
Ergebnisse dieses Gipfels heute
es ist durchwachsen würde ich sagen was
dabei rausgekommen ist es gibt Licht und
Schatten
es soll eine Förderung geben eine
steuerliche Förderung eine sogenannte
degressive AfA die dann denjenigen
zugute kommen soll die Mietwohnungen
bauen leider hat man dabei aber keine
Begrenzung vorgesehen also nach dem
Motto du kriegst ein Zuschuss du kriegst
ein Investitionskostenzuschuss im
Gegenzug musst du aber für eine
bestimmte Zeit garantieren dass die
Miete nicht höher ist als x Euro pro
Quadratmeter das ist aus unserer Sicht
ein Fehler dass man das nicht eingebaut
hat weil jetzt die Gefahr besteht das
mit Hilfe dieser steuerlichen
Erleichterung die höherpreisigeren
Häuser gebaut werden und Wohnungen und
damit eben gerade die Klientel derer die
ein sogenannten Wohnberechtigungsschein
bekommen könnte nicht bedient wird und
das sind die die es am aller schwersten
haben eine Wohnung zu finden Herr
siebenkotten es geht ja nicht nur darum
Wohnraum zu finden sondern auch gibt es
große Ängste dass die Mieten noch weiter
steigen und dazu gibt es ein Kommentar
von einem User namens Leonardo der sagt
Bürger bezahlen heutzutage mal 50
Prozent des Einkommens ich nehme an er
meint damit die sie für die Miete
ausgeben dazu kommen noch die hohen
Stromkosten und Heizkosten wie soll man
das Bezahlen manche konnten vorher schon
nicht mehr also da hat Leonardo
vollkommen recht das Problem ist da nach
unserer Ansicht sollte die Miete nicht
höher sein als ein Drittel des
verfügbaren
netto-haushaltseinkommens wenn es in dem
Fall des Users so ist dass es sogar
schon über 50% sind so habe ich das
verstanden dann ist das viel zu viel das
kann ein Haushalt eigentlich gar nicht
leisten und deswegen ist es auch so
dringend notwendig dass man mit
entsprechenden Maßnahmen bis wir wieder
genug Wohnraum haben die
Mietsteigerungen praktisch ja sagen wir
mal erheblich begrenzt
es gibt Leute die sagen man soll einen
mieten Stopp machen für fünf sechs Jahre
also gar keine Mieterhöhung zulassen und
andere sagen ein Prozent oder zwei
Prozent pro Jahr aber mehr dürfte es
eben nicht sein weil sonst die Leute die
Miete nicht mehr bezahlen können das hat
die Regierung bisher überhaupt nicht
angepackt das ist eine Frage des
Bürgerlichen Gesetzbuches des Mietrechts
dafür ist der Justizminister zuständig
und er war in den Bündnis gar nicht
beteiligt genau inwiefern die Regierung
den Mieterschutz davon nachlässigt
möglicherweise können wir gerne noch mal
sprechen Herr geht dasko ich möchte sie
gerne Fragen mit einem Zitat von der
bauministerin die sagt nämlich heute das
Paket wird viel verändern und vielen
möglich machen sehen Sie das auch so
es wird etwas verändern und ermöglichen
im Bestand das ist auch nicht unwichtig
beispielsweise wird es leichter werden
wenn man über energetische Sanierungen
nachdenkt weil dort Instrumente
eingesetzt wurden die sowohl Mietern als
auch Vermietern helfen werden bloß das
Thema Neubau das ist viel zu kurz
gekommen und wenn wir mal ganz kurz ganz
tief gehen wohnen ist ein Menschenrecht
und wenn das alles so aber nicht mehr
möglich in Deutschland wie das am Anfang
festgestellt haben und das als Messlatte
nehmen viel zu wenig passiert und da
komme ich mal zurück auf diese
steuerliche Regelung die eben
angesprochen wurde die Abschreibung für
Abnutzung das ist ein Instrument dass
die sozial orientierte
Wohnungswirtschaft das sind diejenigen
die wir vertreten Genossenschaften
kommunale Unternehmen die ihr niedrige
mieten nehmen überhaupt nicht nutzen
können das heißt das Hauptinstrument was
angedacht ist wird in bezahlbaren
Wohnraum nicht genutzt werden können
weil unsere Unternehmen das schon
rechtlich entweder nicht dürfen oder so
viel Verlustvorträge haben aus
Investitionen in Klimaschutz und in
Neubau dass das Garantien fertig kommt
das heißt das Hauptinstrument ist für
unsere Unternehmen ein wirkungsloses
Schwert lassen Sie uns bei dem Punkt
Klimaschutz gerade mal bleiben Herr
gehen daschko sie haben eh 40 auch
gerade angesprochen nur mal noch mal ums
erklärt zu haben das ist ein
energiesparstandard der vorsieht dass
bei diesem Standard eben Neubauten nur
40% der Primärenergie verbrauchen oder
das dabei entstehen im Vergleich zu
einem
standardbau der ansonsten gebaut wurde
darauf wird also jetzt verzichtet
Umweltverbände sagen dazu das ist ein
Fiasko das Maßnahmenpaket der Ampel zum
Bauen und Wohnen ist keine
Weichenstellung in eine sozial und
gerechtere und ökologischere Zukunft und
in der Tat beschäftigt das auch einige
Userinnen und User und einer schreibt
hier bei YouTube
gute Isolierung und darum geht es am
Ende bei eh 40 ist doch nicht mehr zu
viel verlangt heute oder muss man die
Klimaschutzziele aufgeben weil man nur
so Wohnungen schaffen kann und wie
nachhaltig ist das
also ich glaube man muss mehrere Dinge
zusammen Denken im Moment haben wir das
Gebäude Energiegesetz durch das bedeutet
dass jeder Neubau tatsächlich auch mit
erneuerbaren Energien dann betrieben
werden muss und das ist auch richtig so
dahinter stehen wir das bedeutet auch
ich muss nicht mehr das letzte Quäntchen
rausdrücken sozusagen aus der Wand und
da verschwinden den übrigen sehr viel
erdölbasiert Dämmstoffe was auch nicht
so richtig toll ist
das bedeutet und dann sprich wenn ich
für den Neubau etwas weniger ausgeben
und dann entsprechend auch die Mieten
nicht so hoch sind und auf der anderen
Seite den Klimaschutz dadurch
gewährleistet dass ich beispielsweise
mit Wärmepumpen arbeite dann ist das
Ding auch völlig in Ordnung und das hat
Robert habe ich auch genauso erklärt und
ich glaube das ist richtig so
schauen wir noch mal auf die Mieterinnen
und Mieter Herr sieben konnten hier
schreibt ein User es dauert ein bisschen
ich lese das Zitat kurz vor meiner
Erfahrung ist dass ich in einer Wohnung
fest Sitze die ich mir eigentlich nicht
leisten kann weil kleinere Wohnungen so
teuer sind dass der Umzug sich nicht
lohnt bleibt mir wohl nur abzuwarten bis
ich irgendwann ins Altersheim muss und
bis dahin kein Geld für irgendwas habe
das ist schon eine sehr absurde
Situation die der User da schreibt
ja aber ich kann mir vorstellen dass er
nicht der Einzige ist dem es so geht in
der Tat das beschreibt die Situation in
der sich die Betroffenen befinden und
die ist zum Teil nahezu ausweglos und
daran kann man ja erkennen wie
wahnsinnig wichtig es ist zusätzlichen
Wohnraum zu schaffen übrigens nicht nur
durch Neubau man kann auch im Bestand
das ein oder andere tun es gibt auch
Ideen zum Beispiel bisherige Büroflächen
um zu funktionieren in Wohnraum das kann
unter Umständen günstig deutlich
günstiger sein als Neubau also es gibt
schon die ein oder andere Idee aber das
wichtigste wäre dass es umgesetzt wird
das heißt also dass das was in ihrer
Grafik am Anfang zu sehen war nicht
weitergeht sondern dass das jetzt
endlich mal man es schafft das Ruder
umzureißen und ich will dazu noch sagen
da gibt es ja die sogenannten
Sozialwohnungen die besonders gefördert
sind der Bundeskanzler der insgesamt von
400.000 Wohnungen gesprochen hat das
haben ja auch eben gezeigt pro Jahr hat
damals gesagt und von diesen 400.000
sollen 100.000 sogenannte
Sozialwohnungen sein tatsächlich hat man
im letzten Jahr glaube ich 23.000
geschafft also weniger als ein Viertel
dessen was notwendig wäre und da
brauchen wir einen Wumms um es mit der
Sprache von Olaf Scholz zu sagen ein
Wumms der ein richtiges klotzen in der
Situation in der Krise in der wir uns
zunehmend befinden umher gegenzusteuern
denn ich habe große Sorgen dass wenn da
nicht bald was passiert wir wirklich
soziale Verwerfungen kriegen und das
rede ich nicht nur so daher sondern die
Gefahr ist wirklich real wir erinnern
uns ja auch an das Jahr 2019 da hat es
Demos gegeben gegen die hohen Mieten in
Berlin es hat Anschläge gegeben auf
Bagger in Leipzig z.B auch privat
Wohnungen wurden angegriffen und
Mitarbeiter von Immobilienfirmen 2019
also dass da große Sprengkraft in diesem
Thema steckt das haben wir damals schon
erlebt aber er geht das gut wenn wir
über den Wumms sprechen der den sieben
Kotten gerade anspricht dann kommen sie
natürlich als Bauunternehmer ins Spiel
und jetzt stellen wir fest dass
Deutschland aber schon jetzt eines der
Länder ist dass die höchsten Baukosten
überhaupt hat was ändert sich denn daran
nach diesem Tag heute
kleine Korrektur
kein Bauunternehmen wir sind
Bestandshalter es sind meistens
Unternehmen die sind über 100 Jahre
Bestands hat das sind Genossenschaften
kommunale Unternehmen wir beauftragen
bauen Unternehmen so was muss ich ändern
damit das Bauen tatsächlich wieder
günstiger wird ich glaube das erste ist
wir müssen selber und an die eigene Nase
fassen das ist immer am besten bevor man
irgendwie jemand beauftragt und Fragen
haben wir in der Vergangenheit die
richtigen Aufträge ausgelöst und wir
versuchen gemeinsam mit unseren 3000
Mitgliedsunternehmen jetzt auch neue
Wege zu gehen schon seit 2018 sind wir
dabei
mit Europa in einer europaweiten
Ausschreibung für serenes Wohnen zu
versuchen die Bauweise etwas in den
Griff zu kriegen dass man durch modulare
fantasievolle Bauweise tatsächlich auch
die Kosten senkt die Qualität geht das
gut darf ich da gerade mal einen Haken
das serielle wohnen das hat der Kanzler
heute auch betont glauben sie wirklich
das in einem föderalen Land wie in
Deutschland es möglich ist dass ein Haus
das in Schleswig-Holstein genehmigt
wurde in einer Kommune in Bayern gebaut
wird glauben Sie dass das tatsächlich
umsetzbar ist
diese Erkenntnis dass das nicht geht die
hat er von uns weil das haben wir
klagenderweise seit Jahren der Regierung
gesagt heute ist es endlich mal gesagt
worden dass das irgendwie total fatal
ist dass das nicht geht weil wir haben
unterschiedliche Geländer in jedem
Bundesland aber das kann der Kanzler ja
nicht ändern sondern das liegt ja in der
Hand der Kommunen und da wiederum kann
der Kanzler ja gar nichts tun
ja das sind die Länder in der Regel die
es ändern könnten das werden die
gemeinsame Bauordnung
warnutzungsvorschriften das ist eben
genau das was jetzt passieren muss wenn
man wirklich Erfolg haben will ist
müssen alle Ebenen betonen die Kommunen
die hatten sie eben schon angesprochen
baulandvergabe gab es dann wichtiges
Stichwort dann die Länder mit
einheitlichen Normen für diejenigen die
bauen wollen und der Bund der das dann
aber auch noch unterstützen muss
zusätzlich weil von den Kosten hier da
sind ja wieder beim Anfang der
Veranstaltung wir würden ja noch nicht
mal im Moment Auftrag vergeben weil
einfach mir kein Auftrag gegeben könnte
bezahlbar ist am Ende von den Mietern
ich würde gerne noch mit je einer Frage
an Sie beide diese Runde beenden Herr
siebenkotten sie haben einen
angesprochen der heute nicht da war
nämlich der Justizminister das Thema
Mieterschutz bewegt hier auch viele klar
sie sagen da muss mehr getan werden aber
es gibt eine andere Seite ein User sagt
noch mehr Mieterschutz macht es doch
noch uninteressanter in neue
Mietwohnungen zu investieren lohnt sich
doch schon jetzt gar nicht mehr vor
allem wenn es auf dem Tagesgeldkonto 4%
Zinsen gibt
also da muss man so richtig Stellung
folgendes sagen sowohl die
mietpreisbremse die bereits seit einigen
Jahren existiert als auch die ansonsten
vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen die ich eben
beschrieben habe
umfassen jeweils nicht den Neubau das
heißt sie sind nicht auf den Neubau
anwendbar weil wir natürlich das Problem
gesehen haben dass dann wenn da die
Miete nicht erhöht werden darf oder nur
minimal erhöht werden darf nicht mehr so
viel finanzielle Möglichkeiten für die
Investition bestehen deswegen haben wir
gesagt diese Regeln sollen für den
Neubau nicht gelten und sie gelten auch
nicht und deswegen glaube ich dass man
den Zusammenhang nicht direkt herstellen
kann mehr Mieterschutz bedeutet weniger
Investitionen ich denke der Mieterschutz
ist nicht das Problem für die Investoren
für die Investoren ist das Problem eher
der Dschungel an verschiedensten
Vorschriften die sie einhalten müssen
und Bauvorschriften in jeglicher
Hinsicht und dann auch noch in 16
Bundesländern völlig unterschiedlich
er geht das gut hier schreibt ein User
meine Freundin und ich verdienen
zusammen knapp 92.000 brutto und wir
können uns keinen dem Lohn angemessenes
Haus leisten das ist bemerkenswert
traurig was glauben sie wird sich daran
in naher Zukunft mit den Beschlüssen von
heute was ändern
nein leider nicht
was braucht es noch damit sich der Name
ist ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen crazy
ich erspare uns denn jetzt mal aber
damit sich dieser User und seine
Freundin mit diesem Lohn ein
angemessenes Haus leisten können was
fordern Sie jetzt damit es in schneller
Zukunft umgesetzt werden kann
also was ist braucht wäre beispielsweise
an der Absenkung der ganzen Nebenkosten
wenn Sie ein Eigenheim oder eine
Eigentumswohnung erwerben wollen sie
sind ja eigentlich schon heute ja
Eigenkapital wenn sie nicht irgendwas
geerbt haben los wenn Sie die
Grunderwerbsteuer gezahlt haben die
Notargebühren bezahlt haben die
Grundbuch Kosten bezahlt haben und
deshalb haben wir auf dem Vorschlag
gemacht übrigens der Regierung der wurde
nicht angenommen in diesem Bereich zu
dem holländischen Beispiel zu folgen da
gibt es Pauschalzahlungen beim
Ersterwerb eines Eigentums
beispielsweise das selbst genutzt wird
dass man dort geringere Notarkosten hat
geringere Grunderwerbsteuer hat das
gleiche fordern wir im Übrigen natürlich
auch für den bezahlbaren Wohnungsbau
Sektor bei der schlägt das dann am Ende
sonst bei der Miete drauf
sagt der Präsident des Bundesverbandes
der deutschen wohnungs- und
Immobilienunternehmen Axel Gedaschko
vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns heute Abend
im Stream dabei waren und vielen Dank
auch noch mal an Lukas siebenkotten den
Präsident des Deutschen Mieterbundes
beide sehr gefragt der Herren an einem
Tag wie diesen wenn ein baugipfel im
Kanzleramt stattfindet danke schön dass
Sie hier dabei waren
und wir sprechen weiter auf dieses Thema
mit einem Blick noch mal auf das ganz
große Ganze und tun das mit einem
Volkswirtschaftler und Experten für
Immobilienwirtschaft hier ist er uns
zugeschaltet Rupert Eisfeld vom Institut
wohnen und Umwelt in Darmstadt grüße sie
Eisfeld was ist ihr Fazit dieses
heutigen gipfeltages
einen schönen guten Tag danke für die
Einladung nun ich bin froh dass die
Bundesregierung den Ernst der Lage nun
verstanden hat und die Verantwortlichen
sich wirklich darum bemühen die aktuelle
Situation wenigstens abzufedern mit der
Zinswende wurde die Situation für den
Wohnungsbau deutlich beeinträchtigt und
wir sehen das jetzt schon seit einem
halben Jahr insofern bin ich froh dass
die Verantwortlichen zunächst mal den
Ernst der Lage verstanden haben denn
alles was heute nicht genehmigt wird und
nicht den Auftrag gegeben wird wird in
zwei bis drei Jahren auch nicht
fertiggestellt werden Sie sagen selbst
ist es Aufgabe des Staates Wohnraum zu
schaffen auch bezahlbaren Wohnraum zu
schaffen wird der Staat dieser Aufgabe
gerecht
nun ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob die
Bundesregierung an sich die Aufgabe hat
Wohnung zu bauen ich denke sie sollte
sich um die Rahmenbedingungen kümmern
und die Immobilienwirtschaft hat die
Aufgabe genug Wohnraum zu schaffen wenn
sich die makrökonomischen Bedingungen
aber derart eintrüben und hier gilt es
nicht auf die EZB zu zeigen oder auf die
Bundesregierung sondern in Richtung
Russland dann hat auch die
Bundesregierung hier einen schweren
Stand aber
dieser Druck der jetzt auf dem
Wohnungsbau liegt und auch auf den
Menschen vor allem in den Großstädten
kann dazu führen dass auch dicke Bretter
gebohrt werden und insofern hoffe ich
dass der Ernst der Lage dazu führt dass
auch gewisse Anpassungen vorgenommen
werden die auf die wir schon seit Jahren
warten darum geht's zum insbesondere das
haben meine Vorredner auch angesprochen
um die Bauordnungen zum Beispiel
nun fragt ihr ein User namens Nils
Pflüger auf Youtube warum baut der Staat
nicht selbst Wohnungen
nun aus makrökonomischer Perspektive
sagt der Volkswirt das ist nicht
unbedingt eine gute Idee man nennt das
sogenanntes crowding-out für eine Euro
den der Staat dort eingibt vertreibt er
teilweise private Investitionen für
deswegen geht es darum die
Rahmenbedingungen zu können zu
setzen so dass die privaten und die
Leute die vor Ort sind tatsächlich das
Bauen was die Leute vor Ort auch gerne
haben würden auf Sicht des Staates geht
es darum für die Breite der Bevölkerung
qualitativen Wohnraum zu sichern
und hier gilt es insbesondere den
besonders Bedürftigen unter die Arme zu
greifen und diejenigen die nicht
qualitativen Wohnraum haben
für alle anderen kann man sich fragen
wie viel Wohnraum wir uns leisten können
und genau da sind Anpassungen eventuell
so Peter sie sind in den gegebenen
Rahmenbedingungen notwendig
nun blickt ihr einen User noch mal ein
bisschen in die Vergangenheit und sagt
früher haben Städte und Kommunen
Sozialwohnungen gebaut und nach und nach
alle verkauft neu gebaut wurde nichts
mehr können Sie damit Carsten Conrads
der diesen Kommentar geschrieben hat
mitgehen
ja es ist ein bisschen
tragisch dass der Staat niedrig Preise
gewohnungen verkauft hat und heutzutage
hochpreisige Wohnungen gehabt hätte
hätte er sie gehalten auf der anderen
Seite muss man die Frage stellen ob der
Staat das bessere Wohnungsunternehmen
ist Sozialwohnungen insbesondere
preisgebundenen Wohnraum mangeln Kranken
immer an der sogenannten fehlbelegung
das heißt dass viele Leute später in der
Wohnung Raum wohnen die dann leider
nicht mehr bedürftig sind insofern ist
mein Vorschlag oder das sagt das
Vorschlag meiner sagt der Ökonomen in
mir das hier die subjektförderung im
Vordergrund stehen sollte das heißt der
Mensch in seiner Wohnung in seinem
Wohnraum oder in seinem nicht
vorhandenen Wohnraum und insofern hat
der Staat auch mit der Ausweisung
des Wohngeldes hier eigentlich schon die
richtigen Weichenstellungen gemacht ob
das ausreicht ist die Frage die aktuelle
mietwohnungsregulierung sorgt dafür das
klangvoll bei meinen vorrät dann auch
schon an das ist teilweise zur Situation
kommt wo eine neue kleinere Wohnung
teurer ist als die Wohnung in der ich
wohne insofern
kann hier überlegt werden wie man denn
zu einem besseren matching zwischen den
mietwohnungsaktie wohnungsmarktakteuren
kommt heißt viele Ansätze die man
verfolgen können es wird auch weil das
vorhin im Gespräch schon angesprochen
wurde
es gibt die Sorge dass es soziale
Unruhen gibt einen User schreibt auch
hier alles sozialer Sprengstoff wie
vorsichtig muss man sein wenn man mit
dem Thema Wohnungen Wahlkampf machen
will welche Sorge haben Sie da
also zunächst mal verstehe ich die
Sorgen der Menschen Wohnraum ist
betrifft das innere Leben das tägliche
empfinden wie es mir geht das empfinde
ich in meiner Wohnung und hier steuern
wird tatsächlich auf einer Situation zu
oder sind schon mittendrin und der sich
die Wohnraum Versorgung auch die
qualitative Hinsicht
für breite für breite Schichten der
Bevölkerung verschlechtern könnte
insofern gilt es eigentlich jetzt alle
Hebel in Bewegung zu setzen so wie heute
auch angetan wurde angegangen wurde
um hierfür Entlastung zu sorgen aber ich
möchte zu addieren dass wir nicht über
den Gesamtdeutschland sprechen
deutschland teilt sich eigentlich auch
wenn
Mietwohnung oder Wohnungsmärkte in denen
noch hohe Leerstand herrscht und
vollen Städte insofern gibt es hier
insbesondere die
mietwohnungsmärkte in den Insel
kernstätten in dem Metropolregionen in
den Blick zu nehmen und dort
helfen auch
entlastungsbauten im Umbau Umland dieser
Metropolen
ein Schätzungen und Ideen und
Lösungsansätze von Rupert Eisfeld vom
Institut wohnen und Umwelt in Darmstadt
vielen Dank Herr Eisfeld dass sie an
diesem Montag hier bei uns im Stream
waren
und damit danke ich auch Ihnen liebe
Userin und User für die vielen Fragen
und Kommentare und ich bin mir sicher
dass zu diesem Thema noch nicht alles
gesagt ist danke schön tschüss